I'm not gonna let the nightshift win me
and my main man boiler about us all the
case isn't that right Charles oh you
know we will we'll call ourselves the
night boys kind of sounds like a male
escort service to midnight men even
worse the dark stallions looks like
we're going with the night boys Boyle
you go through security footage and see
if you can see who brought in that box
okay but I mean I thought since you were
in charge maybe I can be your right-hand
man your Tinker Bell Tinker Bell let me
tell you something Tinker Bell
Tinker Bell is a loyal lieutenant and a
real thorn inside Captain Hook I find
dunya my number two yes I made number
two I hear it why would I ever say that
I swear these perps are so stupid I'd
make a better criminal than any of them
yeah you would you'd be an evil
mastermind and everyone would call you
the handsome bandit Thank You Charles
so how was a date with a floozy we are
not leaving these seats in - give me
some deets all right fine to start it
off a bit rocky but it ended up being
really fun did you kiss did you French
boil I'm not gonna answer that and no
one over the age of 12 says French
that's a yes oh my god you had sex I
could tell because you're glowing uh-huh
Jake no one wants to hear about your sex
life you just asked me repeatedly
because I was rooting for you and Amy
but now I can see her super-serious
about this anonymous gym seductress get
out ducking under police tape I miss
this
what do we got back windows broken two
sets of sneaker prints alarm went off at
11:43 and security arrived at 11:46
perps are already gone okay I'm thinking
classic us I'm thinking old times I'm
thinking roleplay guys okay I'm Jacques
Guillaume and you are unreal know we are
cat burglars on vacation from France I
love it although Inari went to an elite
international school so he does not
speak with an accent oh nice way to
flesh out the characters thank you okay
so I break the back window make my way
over the jewelry case meanwhile you're
standing lookout we're we in the front
door smoking a cigarette
check it ash okay so I am smoking ready
then Oh Jacques roses own cigarettes a
habit he picked up from a prostitute
Marseilles but that is not all he picked
up why do I your characters get STDs mr.
living life all right so I go to the
first case smash steal a bunch of
watches move over to the second case
smash bracelets but then we hear a sound
and I go leave sometimes it's smooth DC
and I know what that means because some
Frenchmen ask you to repeat it in
English just to be sure
boolie sir here yes we gotta get out of
here so we turn to leave you flick your
cigarette using the cane he's in the
cane this is awesome
voila see what I thought on we didn't
have an accent it comes out when he gets
excited anyways I'm back to being a cop
that's all I thought about for the last
six months hurtful okay joke the cars
picking me a name you up in two minutes
you sure you're cool keeping tabs on my
cases well I'm on the cruise you bet I
hope you have a great time hey don't
make any new best friends maybe you
shouldn't go the plan is to lure them
into the fun zone and ambush him any
questions yes
did you miss us quick follow-up did you
ever look up at the moon and wonder if I
was something at it too
yes yo it so I know you're Jake's best
friend and you say that did you get that
on tape
no no didn't say that no you didn't get
it on tape it doesn't matter either way
you screwed up big time
anyway all I'm saying is I know you're
Jake's best friend and you really want
him to win this bed are you kidding
that's the last thing I want Jake moving
in with you is my dream come true your
apartment is two blocks away from mine
Jake will be able to pop by anytime
imagine it he's had a tough day he's
fighting with Amy you know you let
things escalate so just walks over to my
place bottle of wine and hand oh just
talk it out and then by the time that
bottle is finished you come to your
senses and apologize maybe I don't want
to win this bet oh you sweet naive boy I
haven't even begun to pressure you to
I've already written my best man speech
for your wedding oh I'm gonna need you
to get married on a farm a lot of my
jokes rely on that my hutch my hunch my
lovely KC hunch gone Jake sing with me
that's not gonna happen I will literally
never what you gonna do with all that
hunch all that holds you inside your
brain we're gonna solve this case solve
this case right in your face we should
probably leave this prison yep
maybe so but it's what I invented when I
was six because my mom was working so I
had to make dinner for myself my sad
story Trump's your insult Jay Jay Jay
Jay Jay Jay Jay Jay Thank You Boyle
remember that Jake his pants were too
tight yeah yeah hey you know what else
is too tight mmm I was working a case
together again swerve oh yeah we say
noice nots Wirt look I'm so sorry but I
don't think there's room for a third
person on this case Jake we should work
it solo hang on now boy let's not be
hasty I mean Stevie's been tracking
those are off longer than we have and
three heads are better than two
he's a kraut everybody knows that well
what about in the Lion King hmm when Jim
owned and purr boy become friends with
steamboat that's not the names
it's Simba Timon and Pumbaa but I
appreciate you trying it really is a
perfect analogy all right I'm in see if
it can work the case all right Charles
Boyle
welcome to the beatsie boys
the drive-in in a car destination drug
dealers bar that's the mic right over to
Charles we forgot Charles but we can't
turn back cuz we've gone too far oh we
have to turn back though we can't leave
them there's a good rhyme though I think
it's a little off you know what's off
your mouth why Jake let's your stupid
tongue anywhere near him I'll never know
nope I forgot the sugar that's on me
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it
me and Jake are tip buds you know what I
do see it it's mad it looks bad there is
all hail the birthday boy Charles
probably shouldn't have done that in a
police station and not celebrate your
birthday properly
I'd rather get shot you do you boil it
sounds pretty cool but Jake and I
already talked about how we'd play this
we had a pretty sweet combo about it
remember I think we should do
surveillance collect intel and build a
case sure so we all got stories pal look
we need information if we bust in there
and oseroff doesn't have any drugs or
whole operation is blown but I know this
guy all right he never works out at one
place for long I guarantee you he has
drugs on him and if we don't get him now
we never will well too bad for you
because Jake agrees with me we're always
on the same page yes tolya actually
Charles I think Stevie's right you said
Paige I know but he knows this case and
I trust his gut
but hey let's go catch a bad guy
together right gear up police pals hey
what is that there were a PT boys you
didn't even tell him what are you doing
here isn't it your day off
yes stalker it is my day off but I'm
here to meet Charles did you hear what
he did last night
drinka Jake hey what's up your tiny
sleeve
whoa why is there a bowtie in here wait
a minute
Jake Peralta will you be my best man yes
yes yes Wow best man are you gonna set
up shop in a strip club
what kind of shop would I set up hand
sanitizer
I would sell hand sanitizer and no I was
hoping that my bestman duties would be
all whiskey and cigars but this is
Charles were talking about so we've got
two straight days of wedding planning
plus he gave me this to prep fancy bread
gum beans fancy groom and Danish
according to Charles the Danes throw the
most beautiful weddings in the world and
the most violent funerals doubt this was
the last ride after all but it's a big
bust and at least we're going out in a
blaze of glory yeah feels more like a
blaze of crap you're gonna be fine
you're gonna get a new partner his
name's gonna be Heath or Ryan he's gonna
know everything about die hard he's
gonna be super cool jean jacket cool
yeah yeah you can be right
and hey you'll get a cool new partner
too right he'll love fine dining and
musical theater and hearing about every
explicit detail of your sex life over
and over and over just like you yeah
yeah just like me
yes you're right it's gonna be fine I'm
gonna be totally fine without you I'm
gonna check the distance on the
warehouse they're building hasn't moved
still 0.152 for climbers oh oh hey wait
are you just holding up the binocular so
I can't see you cry no yeah I didn't
think so
come to think of it I'm gonna
double-check our building distance as
well see anything nope you know you just
love these binoculars so much and I want
to put them down you know oh man this
case is over I'm gonna miss these
binoculars you do
it's almost 8:30 we're gonna get into
position okay thanks barb
are you guys crying I'm sorry that our
last case was in our best case ever now
I don't say that every case with you is
the best case ever no come on we still
have a drug dealer to bust right you
know what that means Bullitt tornado
that's what I said both times okay
you